- Des phrases-chocs,
des mots crus, les prénoms
de femmes assassinées...
Des cris d'alarmes lancés
dans des lieux très publics.
Une campagne d'urgence née
d'un constat : le nombre
de Françaises tuées par leur
conjoint est en hausse, plus
d'une centaine depuis janvier,
au moins deux par semaine.
L'idée vient de cette militante
de 28 ans qui cherche à secouer
la société française.
MARGUERITE STERN, militante
- On veut inonder les espaces
publics pour rendre ça visible
et que ça s'arrête. C'est notre
revendication. On veut arrêter
de compter nos mortes.
- Un message clair, un hommage
éphémère à ces femmes
souvent anonymes, inconnues.
Voici l'un des visages
derrières ces statistiques :
une femme d'affaire brillante,
entourée d'amis, assassinée
il y a cinq mois.
- C'est dégoûtant,
c'est horrible.
On se sent... salie.
- Marie-Alice Dibon avait
53 ans. Soumise à des violences
psychologiques, tuée parce
qu'elle allait mettre fin
à une longue relation.
HÉLÈNE DE PONSAY
soeur de la victime
- Penser qu'une femme puisse
être assassinée par la personne
qui a partagé son intimité,
je veux dire, c'est...
Elle est ultra vulnérable.
C'est la circonstance la plus
aggravante qu'on puisse imagine.
- Sa soeur, Hélène de Ponsay,
interpelle les autorités et
réclame un système judiciaire
plus rapide à protéger
les femmes en détresse.
- On nous dit que ce sera,
ça permettra des traitements
sous 15 jours. C'est bien,
mais en Espagne, c'est 72 heures
et c'est des tribunaux dédiés.
- Bousculé par une mobilisation
de plus en plus visible,
le gouvernement français promet
d'agir et d'ouvrir plus
d'hébergements d'urgence.
Autre suggestion : davantage
de centres comme celui-ci,
où les femmes en danger
peuvent consulter toute
une gamme de spécialistes,
de la psychologue à l'avocate en
passant par la massothérapeute.
- Cette femme, elle se considère
pas du tout comme victime.
Elle est dans un déni total.
- Un modèle unique en France,
qui vise à mieux coordonner
l'aide offerte aux victimes.
- Elle a besoin
d'être accompagnée...
- La cofondatrice de
l'association Women Safe
mentionne aussi le besoin de
mieux former ceux qui peuvent
aider une femme en détresse,
des médecins jusqu'aux
policiers.
FRÉDÉRIQUE MARTZ, cofondatrice,
Association Women Safe
- Souvent les professionnels
non habitués à rencontrer des
victimes ont tendance à balayer
un peu un dépôt de plainte
et à ne pas donner suffisamment
d'importance à l'écoute et
aux moyens qui doivent être mis
dans une situation d'urgence.
- Tout le monde avait son mot
à dire sur cet homme. Mais
personne l'a dit assez fort.
- Dans ce combat, les militantes
espèrent aussi changer
les mentalités.
- Si aujourd'hui les hommes
tuent, c'est parce que quelque
part dans leur tête, il est
inscrit qu'ils peuvent le faire,
qu'ils ont ce droit de vie
ou de mort sur la femme
qu'ils épousent.
- Et ces rappels macabres
addition n'apparaissent plus que
sur les murs de la capitale,
on en retrouve aussi dans une
dizaine de villes françaises,
et même dans d'autres pays.
Comme quoi le problème
n'est pas que français.
Ici Yanik Dumont-Baron, Radio-Canada, Paris